Oh, ich habe mal einen Audiophlick gemacht mit Trant zu Karate Tiger 1. Das war der fucking beste Audiophlick aller Zeiten. Ich und Trant, wir haben Tränen gelacht, ja. Aber habt ihr das als Podcast gemacht? Ja. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich habe neulich eine App gepitcht bei einem Podcast. Habe ich gehört. Da habe ich mich angesprochen gefühlt. Es wurde nachher sehr oft mitgeteilt. Thorin hat es sogar einmal gesagt. Thorin hat es dann auch gesagt. Ich habe danach auch sehr viele Nachrichten bekommen, wütende Nachrichten. Du hast auch erzählt, dass man so seine eigenen Spiele kommentieren kann. Genau, das gab es auch schon. Tatsächlich ist mir aufgefallen, dass alle Ideen, die man äußert, es gibt, vor allem wenn man die in so einem breiten Rahmen öffentlich macht irgendwie, dann sagen immer Leute, es gibt es schon einfach. Aber ich meine, ich habe jetzt auch den Audiokommentar ja nicht erfunden, so. Aber das Ding ist halt, ich habe das damals dann mit Rand gemacht und dann ist uns dieses File abgeschmiert. Und dann gab es so einen Restore-Bildschirm und der Text war, also es war die einzige Chance, die Datei zu retten. Und der Text war, möchten Sie die Datei wieder herstellen oder löschen? Okay und nein. Ja. Und du wusstest nicht so, die Frage war so formuliert, dass beide Optionen, also es war eine Fifty-Fifty-Chance. Du wusstest nicht, sage ich jetzt okay zum löschen oder sage ich okay zum wiederherstellen. Und wir haben echt, wir sahen es zu dritt da, Trant, Gregor und ich. Sorry, da ist oben diese Einbruchdruck. Wir sind voll perfekt. Undimmst du schon auf, oder was? Klar. Nein. Sicher. Das macht er immer so, dass man sich merkt, damit das Gespräch natürlich ist. Und dann war er wie 50-50-Prozent-Chance. 50-50-Prozent-Chance. Aber wofür hast du dich entschieden? Für okay oder für nein? Wir haben uns für okay entschieden, und zwar falsch, und die Datei war für immer weg. Aber das war das Letzte, wenn diese Meldungen meinen, irgendwie so Anwalt spielen zu müssen, und so komische Suggestivfragen wie, wollen Sie nicht, dass das Programm sich nicht wiederherstellt? Wäre es nicht sehr schade? Und dann gibt es ja, nein und abbrechen. Wenn ich auch immer denke, ist nein nicht abbrechen? Und es gibt auch, manchmal gibt es okay und apply oder sowas. Und Hilfe. Immer Hilfe. Aber mit irgendeiner Einstellung und du sagst, du machst die Einstellung und dann gibt es den OK-Button und den Apply-Button und ich habe das Gefühl, beides ist das gleiche. Ja. Was auch so ein bisschen, es gibt auch mal mit dem Stop- und den Pause-Button, ne, dieses Quadrat und dann nochmal die zwei Streifen, die RTL-Zwei-Ding. Stop, Finger weg vom Stop. Noch nie gedrückt, immer nur Stop, erstmal anhalten. Drop the Stop. Erstmal nur Pause, nicht Stop. Stop ist zu krass. Stop ist wirklich, wenn du keinen Bock mehr hast. Pause ist, wenn du noch einen Rest Unentschlossenheit übrig hast und dir sagst, vielleicht geht's auch. Pause ist so ein bisschen das Nutella-Messer noch so auf die Spüle legen, sodass man sagt so, okay, da passiert noch was. Lebensweisheit, wenn du auf Stop, auf Halt drückst, die beiden Striche, kannst du auch immer noch stoppen. Umgekehrt kommst du nicht wieder zur gleichen Stelle zurück.
Das stimmt.
Das sind so Lebensweisheiten, die wir noch rausfahren.
Das ist einfach auch Lebenserfahrung.
Ich bin nicht 23 Jahre lang nur für diesen einen Erkenntnis. Mehr Erkenntnis habe ich aber auch nicht.
Aber es ist eine wichtige Erkenntnis.
Voll.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn du überlegst, dass dieses, wenn du bei Beziehung zum Beispiel bist, ist es, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn, es ist vorbei, obwohl doch, es würde gehen, du würdest sagen, es ist wirklich aus und dann trifft man sich irgendwie doch. Ja, ja. Das wäre so das. Und dann weiss man, nee, es ist ein Date, es ist nur ein normales Freundschaftliches Treffen. Aber sind wir jetzt Freunde, ja. Sind wir jetzt befreundet oder? Ihr hört schon, Florentin hat seine Etienne-Gardee-Imitation perfektioniert. Was? Kannst du mich imitieren? Das war nur ein Scherz, weil ich... Florentin, sprich mal, wie du jetzt sprichst. Okay, ich spreche mal jetzt kurz als Etienne. Ja, hallo, ich bin der Etienne und ich war früher bei Giga. Das ist perfekt mittlerweile. Oder? Das ist ganz geil. Aber Nils? Alter Schwede, alter Schwede. Tatsächlich ist es mein einziger Traum, den ich noch habe. Es gibt ja so Sachen, die will man noch machen. Ich meine, wir sind jetzt in einem Raum mit einer, sage ich mal, überdurchschnittlichen Erfolgsquote. Ich möchte es einfach nochmal ansprechen. Alle drei, die Anwesenden, sind extrem erfolgreich und haben eigentlich so ziemlich alles erreicht in ihrem Leben, was sie machen möchten. Soll ich gehen oder wollt ihr das alleine machen? Es gibt auch noch so ein paar Sachen, die ich machen will. Es gibt noch so ein paar Sketche, die ich machen will. Es gibt noch ein paar Skripte, die ich machen will. Und bei Rocket Beans bin ich ehrlich durch, es gibt nur noch eine einzige Sache. Geil, sein Arbeitgeber zu sagen, hier will ich einen nichts mehr erreichen, ihr seid nur noch die Rampartier. Ich bin beim New Game Plus, Plus, Plus, Plus, Plus und es wird immer schwieriger, das Spiel. Ich zock's immer noch. Du hast auch alle Isleaks schon gefunden. Alle Isleaks, alle Achievements, es gibt keine Trophies mehr, ich zock's trotzdem noch, das ist das einzige Spiel, was ich habe. Es gibt nur noch eine Sache, die ich machen möchte, und zwar möchte ich ein Moin Moin machen, und zwar möchte ich in diesem Moin Moin alle fünf Moderatoren imitieren, wie die ihre Moin Moins machen. Ich beginne das Moin Moin mit Donny Moin Moin, als Donny, mache dann Moin Moin als Donny, moderiere dann ab, moderiere dann nochmal neu an, als Lars, moderier ab und zieh das komplett durch, alle fünf, bis ich am Ende ich selber bin. Das will ich nochmal machen. Und ich habe mir tatsächlich Videos von allen von euch runtergeladen und habe versucht, das zu... Das wäre meine Frage gewesen. Guckst du alle Moin Moins? Ich gucke sie nicht aktiv, ich gucke sie nur zu Recherchezwecken, eigentlich nur, um mir diesen Traum zu erfüllen. Aber es ist extrem schwer, Leute zu imitieren. Ja. Also es ist so Leute, die halt irgendwie so krass Sachen haben, irgendwie Matthew McConaughey oder irgendwie Daniel Schrocker, Daniel Schrocker, das ist natürlich einfach. Aber jetzt so eine Tienne ist irgendwie, ich habe echt überdurchschnittlich viel Zeit damit verbracht, dir auf die Lippen zu schauen, auf deine zärtlichen, pinken Lippen. Das hat aber andere Gründe und nicht die Imitationsgründe. Und ich habe wirklich versucht, dich zu studieren, aber du bist unknackbar, du bist wirklich. Nee, aber das sehe ich nicht so. Nee, wirklich, Eddie kannst du vergessen. Ich glaube, ich sehe allein schon so ein bisschen so aus.
Das stimmt.
Also die Brille stimmt schon, die Nase stimmt schon, die Frisur ist ähnlich, der Bart ist ähnlich.
Ich glaube, ein paar Jahren sehe ich so aus wie Eddie.
Ja, also das Ding ist halt, ich kriege am Tag locker zwei, drei Tweets von Leuten, die mir irgendwas zuschicken, wo die sagen, da sieht einer aus wie du.
Und mittlerweile ist die Message ...
Ja, aber die Message ist langsam so angekommen, dass ich einfach ...
Und es sind halt auch immer andere Typen, es ist nicht immer der gleiche Typ so, weiss ich, ey, irgendwie, der sieht aus wie Duo, der Typ aus Big Bang Theory, sondern es ist immer jemand anders. Und ich muss jedes Mal auch sagen, ja, stimmt. Und das ist halt das Frustige. Du bist wie der, wenn man bei Sims ins Menü geht und dann der erste Sim, der Default-Sim, der einem angeboten wird, der mit Brille. Ah, den Sim hatte ich auch.
Mit dem habe ich auch richtig.
Mach doch die Brille drauf.
Jetzt, Peppek. Die Brille fehlt, Nerdbrille und dann haben wir schon.
Krieg ich aber auch immer so von euphorischen Fans, die schreiben, ich habe jemanden gesehen, der sieht genauso aus wie dich.
Und dann ist es so ein fetter, haariger Typ, der irgendwie in Arkansas auf dem Boden liegt und sich mit den Bürgern heimt.
Und ich so, cool, danke.
Aber es gibt auch das Video, es gibt ja bei How I Met Your Mother die Folge mit den Doppelgängern.
Und wir haben deinen wirklich gefunden. Und zwar ist es der Typ, das kennen bestimmt Leute auch schon da draußen, der trommelt in der Fußgängerzone. Genau, es gibt so einen Strassenmusiker, der so trommelt aus wie Florentin. Der sieht genauso aus wie Florentin. Und der hat die Bewegung, der hat auch, wenn du dich umguckst, weil jeder Mensch guckt sich ein bisschen anders um, die Geschwindigkeit sich umzugucken und so. Ja, du guckst nicht sehr hasse, du hast einen Huhn umguckt. Ja genau, wie so eine Taube, die immer auf der Hut ist, weil sie immer Angst hat, gegen den nächsten Spind geschubst zu werden. Und bei dir ist es halt so, dass du genauso aussiehst. Und der hat dich schon gesehen. Das ist wirklich fucking true story, ich muss es nochmal zeigen. Aber war dein Ziel für den Tiefen? Nein, ich schwöre, ich wollte mich bauen. Ich wollte, okay, pass auf.
Die Erklärung ist, ich habe einfach versucht, mich zu bauen. Und dann kommt halt der Punkt, das ist eigentlich das, was beim Charaktererstellen bei FIFA meistens Spaß macht, wenn die Frisuren kommen. Weil es gibt ja irgendwie 300 verschiedene Frisuren. Aber alle sind ganz komische. Ja, und dann habe ich ja auf jeden Fall die da so durchgeswitcht. Und dann kommt halt diese Frisur mit dem Gesicht, was ich vorher gebastelt habe, wo ich gedacht habe, das bin ich. Und dann sehe ich das und denke so, fuck, das ist eins zu eins Florentin. Oder ein bisschen Jon Snow auch, Kate Harrington. Schon interessant, ey. Ja, stimmt, so ein bisschen. Aber das Ding ist bei FIFA, du gehst halt Kompromisse ein. Du gehst bei der Nase Kompromisse ein, du gehst bei den Augenbrauen Kompromisse ein,
du gehst bei den Augen Kompromisse ein, du denkst immer, du nimmst immer das, was dich am ähnlichsten sieht. Und am Ende kommt ein komplett anderer. Kommt was ganz anderes raus. Weil du bei allem immer so ein daneben bist. Ja, und vor allem, ich hasse das ja bei Spielen, diese, also ich mach das eigentlich nur bei FIFA Pro-Klasse. Ich meine, der Fussballer sollte schon so aussehen, wie ich mir vorstelle, dass ich als Fussballer aussehe. Aber bei so Rollenspielen, so Fallout oder so,
gibt es ja Leute, die sechs Stunden lang im Generator da sitzen und irgendwie die Nasenhügel anpassen und angleichen.
Ich habe das mal gemacht bei FIFA und man will dann natürlich immer der Zehner sein.
Also ich wollte immer der Zehner sein, schön in der Mitte,
die interessanten Pässe spielen, die coolen Tore machen, Elfmeterschießen, Freischlösser und so.
Und dann habe ich aber immer zwei Meter gross gemacht, wie ich bin. Und dann war ich immer so ein Riesenmensch, einfach so mit Geschwindigkeit von null oder sowas ungefähr und einer Ballbesitzfähigkeit von zwei. Ist dann dann im Mittelfeld rumgelaufen. Bei uns Nils tatsächlich, logischerweise ist er der Zehner hinter den Spitzen, der jeden Ball anfordert. Du spielst ja Pro-Clubs, da musst du quasi mit einem Tastendruck, weil die es nicht kennen. Also du spielst halt feste Positionen und wenn wir zu viert spielen, sind halt vier Positionen besetzt und sieben Positionen logischerweise dann vom Computer. Und wenn der Computer den Ball hat und du willst den Ball haben, dann musst du ihn anfordern. Und Nils fordert dauernd den Ball an. Null den, Null den. Sorry, nee, egal, ist ein anderes Thema jetzt. Nee, nee, es ist krass, ich kenne das, nervt, nervt, nervig. Naja, ähm, fangen wir jetzt eigentlich schon an mit dem Bock. Ja, wir freuen uns sehr, dass du da bist erstmal. Wir freuen uns sehr, Etienke hat es endlich geschafft zu uns, wir sind gerade nach der Chat-Duell-Aufnahme, Stefan muss gleich weg, Stefan muss gleich wieder zum Zug, es ist unglaublich energetisch geladen gerade. Deswegen reden wir auch so schnell. Bei den Rocket Beans in Hamburg. Das ist unfassbar, was du für ein Leben führst so. Ja, es ist eigentlich nicht so. Ich fahr einmal im Monat zu euch, vielleicht einmal zwei Monaten und dann kommt man mit dem Zug hin und fährt dann mit dem Zug wieder zurück. Wenn das mein Leben ist. Aber ich finde, das ist also, du bist 23, das ist Hammer. Also du hast, ey, du bist Ich kann Fahrkarten buchen, ich kann mit dem Zug nach Hamburg fahren, alleine, manchmal habe ich noch so einen Schlüssel um den Hals hängen, wenn ich verloren gehe.
Aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, du bist doch schon unfassbar nah dran an dem, was du sein willst, das weiß ich gar nicht, ich behaupte es einfach mal. Geht's?
Nein, aber ich mein so jetzt mal zum Beispiel beruflich, ja, du willst Comedy machen und
du bist fucking Comedy-Autor gewesen für die beste Late-Night-Sendung, die Deutschland
zu beaten hat mit 23.
Du bist mal ein fucking Comedy-Autor gewesen für die beste Late-Night-Sendung, die Deutschland zu bieten hat mit 23. Du bist bei den fucking Rocket Beans irgendwie cool. Ja, das ist schon wieder. Nee, aber jetzt mal im Ernst, das ist ja schon in einem Alter, wo andere noch orientierungslos irgendwie Philosophie studieren. Oder im freiwilligsten Jahresjahr. Ja, oder nochmal zur Bundeswehr gehen oder so. Oh, das war eine Spitzwege gegen Florentin. Nee, es war überhaupt nicht, es war erst danach. Aber hat er so aufgefasst? Ich wollte eigentlich Soziologie sagen, aber es ist mir nicht eingefallen. Und dann habe ich das Zweite gesagt, was mir eingefallen ist, das kommt wahrscheinlich von Chat-Duell, Philosophie. Und dann ist mir eingefallen, fuck, das ist ja genau Florentins Thema. Aber ich habe tatsächlich eher einen Budi gedacht, der ja seinen... Du wolltest einen anderen Menschen beleidigen. Ja, aber ... Ne, das stimmt. Also man hat ... Ja, ich bin auch sehr ehrgeizig und habe mich dann früh damit beschäftigt und so, wusste halt schnell, was ich machen wollte und so. Ja, aber das alleine schon. Dass ich in die Unterhaltung gehen wollte und so was. Aber das ist noch ... das ist a long way. Also es ist noch ein langer Weg bis zum SNL-Presenter. Also wenn ich irgendwann SNL-hoste, das ist schon das Ziel, oder Florentin? Irgendwo schon, ja. Aber finden wir nicht auch? Also ich meine, ich hatte früher immer den Traum, also natürlich wollte ich Conan O'Brien sein, aber wenn das nicht klappt, war die Option B für Conan O'Brien zu arbeiten. Und ich habe mir dann immer überlegt, ob ich mich mal bewerben soll als deutscher Praktikant bei Cone O'Brien, ob die nicht auch Bock hätten und so.
Und dann habe ich immer ganz schnell irgendwie die Angst gekriegt von dem, was man so liest und mitkriegt. Wir Deutschen sind in Amerika einfach nicht das gleiche. Also wir haben ja so, wir kennen alles von denen. Wir sind eigentlich, wir fühlen uns manchmal so nah der amerikanischen Comedy und wir kennen uns aus und wir kennen vielleicht sogar Autoren aus irgendwelchen Late-Name-Shows. Wir kennen uns teilweise besser aus als der Amerikaner an sich. Aber umgekehrt ist für die Deutschland genauso wie Kasachstan. Vielleicht nicht ganz so schlimm, weil die schon mal auf Natur oder so da waren, aber generell machen die keinen Unterschied zwischen Italien, Deutschland, Frankreich, Spanien, Ungarn. Das sind alles irgendwelche Länder, die nicht Amerika sind, die auf ihrem Radar des Entertainments nicht wirklich stattfinden. Das steht man natürlich voll, weil die einfach das beste Angebot haben. Also die haben auch keinen Grund dafür, aber tatsächlich meinte Jan Böhmermann, als der bei uns mal zu Gast war, hat er gesagt, dass er bei Seth Meyers war und da halt auch empfangen wurde wie ein Late-Night-Gott auf eine Art. Die haben das schon respektiert. Ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen dann diese amerikanische Outgoing. Ja, aber das ist glaube ich gelernt. Ich glaube, das machen die da aber auch mit einem Soapstar. Also nichts gegen Jan Böhmermann, die werden schon wissen, wen sie da einladen und dass der irgendwie eine Relevanz hat durch diese Merkel-Geschichte und so. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die in irgendeiner Form jetzt gewusst hätten, was der so für Sketche gemacht hat oder sowas. Aber ich habe immer das Gefühl, wir waren ja ein paar Mal in New York und dieses Jahr auch nochmal und es ist einfach, man fühlt sich immer als der ununterhaltsamere Teil in einer Konversation mit dem Amerikaner. Ich fühle mich immer wie der, der ich weiß nicht, gerade interviewt wird, eher so der, nicht der, der gerade so das Gespräch schmeißt und der der unterhaltsame Part ist und so. Dann kommt man nach Deutschland und fühlt sich wieder cooler. Ich habe immer in Amerikas Gefühl, man ist einfach uncool im Vergleich, weil die einfach immer dieses, die auch, die kann man jedem am Strassenrand Gags machen, alle ballen sofort die Pantschle jetzt um die Ohren und machen mit ein Steigen ein und da machst du so fast so ein Improartiges Stück mit einem Fremden, den du seit zwei Minuten da am Straßenrand gesehen hast oder so, keine Ahnung, das ist einfach so fix. Ich glaube, das aber auch mit diesen unendlichen Möglichkeiten und dieser krassen mit diesen Chancen, die man aufwegt, hat auch eine Schattenseite. Wir waren ja bei in New York, in der UCB zum Beispiel und da haben wir uns ein paar Impro-Shows angeschaut, also diese legendäre As-Cat-Impro-Show. Und ich habe allen, die da performt haben, folge ich auf Instagram, allen. Und gucke, was die auch so privat machen und so. Und auch bei UCB ist es auch so, die gibt es halt schon wahnsinnig lange, und da war auch schon Amy Poehler und Cezan Zari und so, und die haben dann immer so eine Hall of Fame, so, ah, der hat jetzt da gerade einen Emmy gewonnen, der hat gerade da einen Emmy gewonnen. Und auch auf Instagram spiegelt sich das so, dass die, die zusammen performt haben und dann schreibt er, ah, der ist jetzt hier bei dieser Show und der ist bei dieser Show und ich will es ihnen jetzt nicht konkret unterstellen, aber gerade wenn du diese unglaubliche Nähe zum absoluten Olymp hast, so weißt du, du bist halt von einem Tag bist du in irgendeinem Keller in New York und findest nicht genug, um zu leben, am nächsten Tag sagt halt irgendwie irgendeine Late-Night-Show, hey, Amy Poehler, hast du Bock, da machst du ein Segment, zack, bist du bei SNL und alle anderen sitzen halt immer noch in ihrem Keller und sagen, ja, wir sind nicht bei SNL. Ich glaube, dass dieser Unterschied auch viele einfach hinten rauslässt, die dann einfach sagen, fuck, ich bin nicht so wesentlich weniger lustig als Amy Poehler, wir haben zusammen performt, wir haben uns die Gags zugeworfen. Sie ist jetzt bei SNL und ich nicht mehr.
Ja, da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht,
aber das hast du ja in Deutschland auch.
Aber nicht so stark, weil du bist halt nicht bei SNL,
sondern du bist halt bei Mike Krüger.
Und dann denkst du, Mike Krüger, mein Gott, so geil ist das auch nicht.
Ja, okay, das gibt es einfach, weil es generell
Nichts gang, jetzt geht
der Twitter-Beef wieder los.
Nein, aber ich meine, das liegt einfach daran, dass es in Deutschland generell
nicht so viel geilen Scheiss gibt. Das mag stimmen, aber gerechnet auf die Zuschauer, oder ich meine, Amerika ist einfach, 300 durch 80 sind fünf? Wenn du das will, wenn Amerika... Will ich jetzt nichts mehr so sagen. Also Amerika ist einfach fünfmal so gross, dann haben die halt fünfmal so viel geile Shows ungefähr.
Also das ist einfach, auch so muss man es, finde ich, sehen.
Und die Chance, also da dann reinzukommen, ist natürlich auch viel kleiner.
Also das ist halt wie ein Sechser im Lotto zu gewinnen in Amerika.
Es gibt ja von Seinfeld gibt es ja diesen Comedian, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den Film kennt, habt ihr den mal gesehen?
Der Comedian?
Ja, das ist quasi eine Doku über ihn und wie heisst der andere? Ja, der ist mega unsympathisch. Genau, dieser unsympathische Film. Der ist mega unsympathisch. Und das ist ganz schön, weil er ist so ein junger, also Seinfeld wird einfach so verfolgt, wie er so seinen Kram macht und Material sammelt und ist halt schon so diese Legende. Genau. Und dieser andere, ich habe seinen Namen vergessen, Lenny Ornstein oder irgendwas so. Orny. Orny, Orny Adams. Orny Adams, ja. Genau, Orny Adams. Und er ist so ein super ehrgeiziger Stand-Up-Comedian, der versucht, unbedingt irgendwie reinzukommen. Und er sagt eigentlich, und dann gibt es so ein Gespräch, wo Seinfeld auf ihn irgendwann trifft, es werden so beide, ähm, werden so quasi dokumentarisch verfolgt und dann treffen sie sich irgendwann und tauschen sich aus. Und Orny Adams erzählt dann so, ja Mann, du hast es halt geschafft, du hast deine Sitcom gehabt, du hast Multimillionen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann erzählt Seinfeld ihm so eine Story, so eine Metapher-Story. Ich kriege die jetzt auch leider nicht mal halb so cool hin, wie Seinfeld sie erzählt hat. Aber er erzählt dann halt von einer Weihnachtsband, die Instrumente spielt, an Weihnachten einfach von Häusern zu Häusern zieht und dort für die Leute irgendwie Weihnachtslieder spielt. Und das Flugzeug irgendwie eine Notlandung macht und sie steigen aus und müssen irgendwie mit ihren Instrumenten durch den Wald laufen und die schweren Instrumente schleppen durch den Schnee und sie sind nass und es ist beschwerlich und alles möglich. Sie kommen an ein Haus und gucken durchs Fenster und sehen dann, durchs Fenster sehen sie so eine Familie und es ist offensichtlich eine wohlhabende Familie, Vater, Mutter, zwei wunderschöne Kinder, ein toll geschmückter Weihnachtsbaum und alles ist perfekt so und sie gucken so durchs Fenster und klitschnass, gucken sich so an und sagen, siehst du das? Und dann sagt der Troubert das zu dem einen, ja siehst du das? Und dann sagt der andere, ja wie kann man nur so leben, antwortet er. Die Essenz der Geschichte ist halt, dass wenn du Künstler bist, dann machst du das, weil du es nicht anders kannst. und du denkst gar nicht daran, ich will in eine Sitcom oder ich will Millionen machen, sondern du machst es, weil es nicht anders geht. Du machst es, weil du einfach, du läufst durch die Welt und du siehst Sachen anders als andere. Dir fallen, wo ein anderer einen Reissverschluss siehst, siehst du irgendeinen anderen Shit, jetzt Insert geile Idee. Klettverschluss. Ja, perfekt. Und du läufst, sorry, es ist so einfach. Aber das meine ich jetzt. Siehst du, du kannst auch in dem Moment, es ist, weißt du, es geht einfach nicht anders. Und ich glaube, das ist so die Message, dass man einfach das andere Glück, das kannst du eh nicht beeinflussen, ob einer kommt und dir die Sitcom gibt oder Saturday Night Live oder Cone O'Brien oder was weiss ich, was du machen musst ist, du musst diese Leidenschaft haben und das hat Seinfeld gemacht, der hat einfach gemacht, der ist, wenn man jetzt sein jüngstes Stand-up anguckt auf Netflix, da erzählt er das ja auch und man weiss es ja auch so, genau und man weiss es ja auch so über seine Biografie, der ist halt jeden Abend raus in diese Stand-up-Kneipen und hat dort gelebt für diese Craft. Und das ist halt ein anderer Anspruch, als zu sagen, ich gehe raus, weil Stand-Up gerade gut ankommt und will damit in einer Sitcom-Lampen. Zwei Dinge, solche erfolgreichen Leute sind nie faul. Ich kenne keinen, den ich total doll mag, den ich vergötter und wie ich sein will, wie er, der faul ist. Und ich kenne auch keinen, es gibt keine verkannten Genies. Es gibt keine Leute, die, also gefühlt gibt es alle Leute, die was richtig drauf haben und so, die kriegen genug Chancen. Die kriegen dann auch mal irgendwann die SNL Audition oder so. Auch wenn die ersten nicht klappt, dann sind die zumindest in den Kreisen da. Und Jimmy Fallon hat auch irgendwie tausende SNL-Auditions gehabt, die nicht funktioniert haben und dann irgendwann wurde er genommen. Und Louis C.K. war der einzige an einem Open-Mic-Abend, der nicht genommen wurde für SNL. Und ich meine, trotzdem war das ja geschafft. Ich glaube, man kriegt einfach viele Chancen. Und wenn du halt einfach arbeitest andauernd, dann kannst du auch nur irgendwann zu der Elite gehören. Ich glaube dann, ja. Aber auch das, was Florentin gesagt hat, zu kommen, von wegen, dass es auch eine Care-Seite hat und so, das stimmt auf jeden Fall auch. Aber das ist, finde ich, wie gesagt, die Care-Seite hast du immer, wenn du versuchst, was zu erreichen oder dass du, dass manche Leute werden erfolgreich mit vielleicht Sachen, die schlechter sind als das, was du machst. Und vielleicht sogar gerade bei Comedy und gerade in Deutschland ist es, glaube ich, noch viel krasser, weil wenn ich mir angucke, was in Deutschland erfolgreich ist, da kann man ja gut mal gute Arbeit Originals als Beispiel für unerfolgreich nehmen, im Sinne von Klickzahlen verglichen mit anderen Sachen, die im gleichen Segment fischen. Und für mich, und das sage ich nicht, weil ich jetzt hier bei euch seite, das wisst ihr auch, ich feiere das total, was ihr macht. Ich finde, es ist mit das Beste, was ich Sketch-Comedy-mässig seit L'Oreal in Deutschland gesehen habe. Das meine ich echt ernst. Gleichzeitig sehe ich, wie ihr aber auch, also die Klickzahlen sind ja okay, aber sind halt nicht wie wenn Aporet in Chicken Fingers badet oder irgendwas, ja. Oder wenn Aaron Troschke irgendwelche Girls auf der Gamescom sagt, haha, du hast aber grosse Titten. So, ja, und das ist natürlich auch ein Faktor den ich persönlich, bei Rocket Beans sehe ich das ähnlich, also jetzt nicht nur im Comedy-Bereich, sondern generell im Entertainment-Sektor oder im Gaming-Sektor. Man sieht Leute, die sind viel erfolgreicher, viel erfolgreicher, kassieren die grosse Kohle, machen irgendwie alles oder so. Ich sehe es mit Late Nights, wenn ich sehe, mit welchem Engagement wir da rangehen, mit welchem Budget und wenn ich dann sehe, wie ein Joko und Klass, den ich das gönne, weil die es auch gut gemacht haben, wenn ich sehe, wie die durch die fucking Decke gegangen sind, mit mehr oder weniger dem gleichen Showkonzept. Ich sage nicht, dass die es geklaut haben, weil wir haben auch nur Wayne's World geklaut, ja. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, wer hat es gemacht, wer hat es erfunden, aber im Prinzip... Schon ihr. Aber im Prinzip haben sie schon mehr oder weniger fast zum gleichen Zeitpunkt das gemacht, was wir auch ähnlicherweise gemacht haben und sind einfach durch die Decke gegangen. Und zwar sowas von, und du konntest ja die Karriere von Joko und Klaas, konntest du ja wirklich auch verfolgen, ja. Jeden Award gewonnen, jeden Preis gewonnen, überall so, während Giga Pleite gemacht hat und wirklich sich das komplett in die andere Richtung bewegt. Und du sitzt dann schon da und fragst dich, ist der Unterschied so gross gewesen, sind die wirklich so viel besser gewesen oder haben die vielleicht einfach Glück gehabt zur richtigen Zeit, am richtigen Ort, mit den richtigen Förderern oder was auch immer?
Gut, aber wo sind die jetzt? Ja, immer noch fucking eben. Ja, stimmt. Ja, nicht schlecht. Ja. Oh man, ey. Ja, aber es ist halt, es ist auch eine Lotterie. Und vor allem, dann gibt es in Deutschland auch nur einen Sender dann, irgendwie bei ProSieben oder so, der dann, das war auch dann Neo Paradise und so. Also es gibt auch, was ich höre, was ich auch nicht verstehe einfach, dass man immer hört, ja wir haben keine Sendeplätze mehr. So oft werden Projekte, die ich total toll finde, nicht umgesetzt. Da kriegen manche Leute niemals was von mit, dass es überhaupt existiert, weil Sendeplätze nicht existieren. Was ist denn das für ein altes Konzept, Sendeplätze? Dann macht es im Internet oder so. Ich meine, öffentlich-rechtliche, die haben ja nicht nur Geld, um was im Fernsehen zu machen, sondern dann sollen die jetzt einfach im Internet auch. Ja gut, das ist ja Funk dann quasi. Ja gut, aber die haben auch, ich meine auch fürs Fernsehen, auch wirklich einfach der WDR, der nur fürs Fernsehen was produziert, der hat halt auch, macht manche Sachen nicht, weil der keinen Sendeplatz dafür hat. Das ist auch einfach, und dann hast du in Amerika halt auch immer mehr wahrscheinlich und ja, mehr Chancen. Ja, ich finde es halt auch, also ich war jetzt, als wir auf der E3 waren, dann da waren wir auch im nee, wie hieß der Laden, ich habe es vergessen, auch in einem Stand-O-Comedy-Store. Im Comedy-Store waren wir genau und das war ja auch so krass, weil offensichtlich hatten die nicht genug Zuschauer für, das waren, eigentlich waren es zwei Shows, glaube ich, aber die hatten für die aber die hatten für die zweite Show nicht genug Zuschauer oder so und haben uns einfach da drinnen sitzen lassen und haben einfach dann weitergemacht. Ah, cool. Und wir, das war wirklich unangenehm, weil am Anfang war es mega, es war ein richtig gutes, es war hier, Anthony Jeselnik war da und Judd Apatow und noch ein paar andere. und es war richtig richtig gut und wir waren alle mega drauf wir richtig, das ist ja sauteuer alles. Wir haben es uns richtig gut gelassen. Wir haben da die Getränke und das Essen. Und saßen da so eine richtige, die haben uns richtig, die haben direkt gefragt, wo wir herkommen, weil die uns Lauchs angesehen haben, dass wir nicht Amis sind. Haben uns direkt in die erste Reihe gesessen und wir wussten, jedem Stand-Up-Comedian wurde gesagt, those are the Germans, damit er schon mal, wenn er irgendwie Crowdwork macht, ungefähr weiss, wo er hingehen muss oder was er sagen soll. Und dann sitzen wir so da und es ist original und wir braven Deutschen haben uns nicht getraut, aufzustehen und zu gehen. Und es war ja auch mega unhöflich, weil es kam immer ein neuer Stand-Up-Comedian und es wurde immer schlechter. Am Anfang kamen die Stars und am Ende kam, ich hab schon seinen Namen vergessen, irgendein wirklich abgefuckter, experimenteller Typ, der irgendwie seinen Periscope-Stream live gemacht hat.
Er so, hey guys, I have to periscope this. Zehn Minuten seines Acts ging darum, dass er sein Handy nicht richtig hinstellen konnte und dann so ganz schlecht Crowdwork gemacht hat.
Und es war wirklich veranstalter. Und es sind immer mehr Leute gegangen und am Ende waren ungefähr neun Leute da, und sieben davon waren wir. Oh, wie unangenehm. Und wir haben wirklich so da gesessen, der Arsch hat wehgetan, wir wollten danach, das war der vorletzte Abend, wir wollten, nee, es war der letzte Abend, Comedy-Folge einfach. Wir wollten eigentlich da noch nach Hause, weil wir waren ja ein grosses Team da und waren nur mit sieben Leuten in diesem Comedy-Store und wollten eigentlich mit den anderen noch irgendwie den Abend Abschluss feiern und irgendwie und es war dann schon ein Uhr nachts, wir waren irgendwie seit neun Uhr da und es hat nicht aufgehört und dann haben wir uns alle so angeguckt und gedacht, können wir jetzt gehen oder nicht? Comedy ist, sobald es irgendwie in die falsche Richtung geht, also sobald du Comedy kann so schnell eine Strafe sein, einfach Folter. Ich glaube, ach Gott, das ist Ja, aber aber vor allen Dingen dann während eines Acts aufzustehen und zu gehen. Und wir haben jedes Mal gedacht, okay, das war jetzt bestimmt der Closing-Act, jetzt können wir gleich... Und dann kommt wieder einer. Ja, vor allem, du willst ja nicht während des Acts gehen, du willst aber auch nicht danach gehen, weil dann gibst du dem Nächsten sofort das Gefühl, der denkt sich, ja, guck doch mich, ihr habt mich doch gar nicht bewertet. Mir hat es auch mega leid genommen. Dann sind wir natürlich irgendwann bei diesem verransten Ty dann aufgestanden gegangen und er hat natürlich direkt noch Sprüche gebracht, während wir rausgehen. Aber wie gut, dass zwei Leute überbleiben und jetzt zwei Leute spricht durchs Mikrofon. Ja, ohne Scheiss, ey. Weißt du was, ich setze mich zu euch. Soll ich zu euch kommen? An den Tisch oder soll ich einfach noch, soll ich bei euch das Mikro sprechen? When Comedy Goes Too Long. Also das war echt, das war echt hart. Diese Position des Menschen auf der Bühne kann umschlagen von der grösste Gott und Rockstar der Welt bis zu du armes Würstchen innerhalb von einer Sekunde. Mir war es auch so unangenehm, weil du hast, wir waren jetzt ein paar Mal in Amsterdam, haben Comedians gesehen. Sorry, was man da so zu sprechen, sie spricht wie ein anderer Mensch. Wo ist Stefan? Und dann hast du immer gefragt, Etienne, du hast immer geschrieben, wie war es denn, weil du immer mitbekommen hast, dass wir da waren. Und immer war das so unangenehm, immer zu schreiben, Chris Rock hat mir nicht mehr gefallen und Ricky Gervais hat mir nicht gefallen. Ich dachte mir, der muss jetzt denken, wir sind die arroganten Comedy-Nerds, die aus Köln immer nach Amsterdam fahren. Genau, letztens waren wir für Chris Rock in Amsterdam. Genau, das steht halt auf meiner Bucketlist. Ich bin halt riesen Chris Rock Fan und ich war wirklich traurig. Bei Ricky Gervais, da fand ich seine Stand-Ups immer gut, aber das war nie so das Beste vom Besten, finde ich. Ich bin ein großer Ricky Gervais Fan, aber eher so in Interviews oder Extras oder Office und so Geschichten, einfach so als Typ. Aber seine Stand-Ups fand ich jetzt nie überragend. Chris Rock fand ich schon immer, war schon so auf meiner Top Five of all times. Ricky Gervais ist mein absoluter Held, irgendwie über ihn bin ich zu Comedy gekommen, über The Office und hab alles konsumiert, seinen Podcast, die Radioshow, XFM, alles. Und er fand auch seine Stand-Ups immer gut und deswegen hat es mich echt ein bisschen getroffen, als der Stand-Up, der Live-Stand-Up dann in Amsterdam einfach nicht so gut war. Und das war dann so ein bisschen so... Das ist doch ein braver Euphemismus. Ja, ja, aber es ist so, wir haben zwei Ex in Amsterdam gesehen, einmal Louis C.K. Und es war wirklich ein neues Erlebnis. Es war wirklich so, wirklich mal live was zu sehen. Und es ist wirklich was ganz anderes. Man ist so von, ja, man guckt halt und lacht, ist okay, bis zu für 19 minuten in einer anderen welt du bist im comedy himmel du denkst an nichts anderes und du bist in dieser welt und denkst dir einfach und es hört auf und du wachst wie auf einem traum aus und denkst dir wow das ist und wir hatten wie die schlechte sitze waren wahnsinnig weit weg bühne links irgendwie wir haben mehr auf die bildschirme geguckt als auf ihn weil er so klein war unten in amsterdam aber aber trotzdem, dieser Live-Act hat so krass gemacht und glaube ich die Erwartungen daraus und die Erwartungen, dass Ricky Gervais mein persönlicher Held war, haben den Ricky Gervais-Auftritt echt ernüchternd gemacht. Und es ist so, du sitzt da und denkst, ich will lachen, ich will lachen, ich will es lustig für. Ich gönne dir das ja. Bitte, aber es war wirklich echt enttäuschend. Also war es schlecht, weil er einen schlechten Tacker oder war es Material?
Nee, ich glaube, es war von der Thematik, es war sehr selbstreferentiell. Er hat ständig darüber geredet, wie er bei den Emmys moderiert hat und dass er ja wollte, dass man die Leute verarscht und jeder muss verarscht werden. Und denkst du so, ja, okay, aber dann gib mir doch so ein paar Gäste. 80% des Materials waren einfach Tweets, die er zitiert hat von sich selber, wo er meinte, er hatte mal einen Tweetsstreit recht. Das war wirklich alles. Und das war so enttäuschend. Und ja, die Zugabe war dann, wie er von seinem Bruder gesprochen hat, der immer coole Gags gemacht hat bei der Beerdigung seiner Mutter usw. Und die ganze Zugabe waren Gags von seinem Bruder. Ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit so, den will ich gerne mal live sehen. Ja, und die waren alle besser als einige. Den Bruder möchte ich gerne mal live sehen. Der ist bestimmt ein lustiger Typ. Da hatte ich wirklich so das Gefühl, dass ihn den Erfolg vielleicht auch so ein bisschen aufgefressen hat. Er kokettiert konstant damit, dass er jetzt so wahnsinnig erfolgreich ist und wahnsinnig reich. Und es ist zu einem Grad lustig, aber irgendwo, glaube ich, ist auch ein Kern so. Wenn du dann nur noch drüber redest, dass du einen Tweet rausgehauen hast. Er ist schon ein bisschen eingebildet, glaube ich. Er retweetet ja auch dauernd, wie erfolgreich seine Stand-up-Tour ist. Was ich auch immer so ein bisschen... Ich meine, so ein gesundesbewusstsein ist ja immer okay, aber er ist schon sehr unbescheiden, was die eigene Wahrnehmung angeht, ist ja auch okay, ist ja auch ein Teil der Persona oder so, aber also bei Bill Burr, war die auch bei Bill Burr? Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, haben wir uns auch gesehen, ich weiß schon nicht mehr, weil ich war auch, ich war, das ist ja mein Momentaner zumindest, meine momentane Nummer eins.
Und ich bin immer so hin und her gerissen, weil ich fand es auch genau wie du es gesagt hast, ich war wirklich wie in Hypnose. Der hat ja über zwei Stunden gemacht. Und ich habe jedes Wort auch gesaugt und war gleichzeitig so, hoffentlich endet es niemals.
Und hing wirklich an seinen Lippen und bin auch echt Fanboy und höre mir seinen Podcast an und gucke mir auf YouTube immer irgendwelche Interviews und was weiss ich an und habe den wirklich studiert. Und im Prinzip ist er die Art Stand-Up, die ich gerne machen würde. Also wenn ich Stand-Up machen würde, ist er so, von der Person her geht es in die Richtung, wie ich es mir vorstelle. Und es ist aber gleichzeitig so unerreichbar, dass ich gar keinen Bock habe, Stand-up zu machen. Weißt du, was ich meine? Ja. Es gibt Leute, die dann diesen Ehrgeiz haben, und das sind wahrscheinlich auch, die werden vielleicht auch Profisportler, die dann fünfmal auf die Fresse fallen und dann nochmal aufstehen und sagen, ich kriege das aber irgendwann hin. Und ich fliege halt einmal auf die Fresse und sage so, fuck, ich habe keinen Bock auf die Fresse fliegen, macht mir noch weniger Bock, als erfolgreicher Stand-up-Comedian zu werden. Und ich fliege halt einmal auf die Fresse und sage so, fuck, ich habe keinen Bock auf die Fresse. Auf die Fresse fliegen macht mir noch weniger Bock, als erfolgreicher Stand-Up-Comedian zu werden. Und ich, also abgesehen davon, dass ich auch irgendwie dann denke, ich bin auch nicht klug genug. Ich finde halt, das ist unfassbar, also das ist meine Faszination mit Stand-Up ist halt auch bei guten Stand-Up-Comedians, ob das ein Louis C. Case oder ein Chris Rock oder ein Bill Burr oder wie auch immer, dass das unfassbar smarte Typen sind, weil es ist ja nicht eben, man kann es auch, also ich kann es zumindest nicht immer genau sagen, warum es das ist, ich kann nur sagen, ich merke den Unterschied zwischen einem, der einfach feststellt, ah ja, weiß ich nicht, Flugzeug essen, ha ha ha, oder noch so ein, der dir noch was so mitgibt, Das ist nicht einfach nur ein Joke, es ist nicht einfach nur ein Setup und eine Punchline, sondern es ist, da schwingt noch viel mehr, da spielt eine Attitude, also eine Einstellung, eine Persona, aber auch so Sachen, wo du drüber nachdenkst, denkst, ja, nicht ganz unrein. Also da kommen so viele Sachen zusammen. Und das vermisse ich zum Beispiel bei deutschen Stand-Ups so viel. Das ist eine Schwierigkeit, das festgestellt. Ja, aber man kann, das ist ein abstraktes Gefühl auf eine Art, aber man kann das nicht so richtig auf den Worte fassen. Aber es ist, glaube ich, einfach oft der Weg, noch mal mehr um den Gag herum. Einfach noch mal nicht das Offensichtliche zu nehmen, nicht die Mann-Frau-Fernbedienung, wer hat die Fernbedienung-Rolle, sondern noch mal weiterzugehen. Oft haben die ja auch noch so eine gewisse Haltung und geben halt Leuten dann noch was mit irgendwie auf eine Art.
Das ist schon schwierig, das genau zu abstrahen. Aber trotzdem lassen sich nie so, also ich meine gerade Bill Burr ist ja auch einer, der unfassbar polarisiert, der jetzt auch nicht unbedingt der liberalste Stand-Up-Comedian ist. Also ist, glaube ich, kein Trump-Supporter, aber ist auch keiner, der jetzt nur sagt, keine Ahnung, der hat ja auch auf Hillary genauso geschissen wie auf Trump und so.
Aber der geht irgendwie, der traut sich manche Sachen so einfach so klar und deutlich zu sagen und kommt damit davon, ohne dass du denkst, was für ein dummes Arschloch oder so, sondern irgendwie, ich weiss nicht, das ist, das finde ich irgendwie, ja, wenn du wirklich einfach so hart in deinem Humor sein kannst, ohne, auch Anthony Jeselnik, ja, der sagt ja so schlimme Sachen eigentlich und ich versuch das dann immer mir vorzustellen, wie wäre das in Deutschland, der hätte keine Chance hier. Tatsächlich habe ich mal ein Stand-up gemacht und da kam vor mir einer dran und der wollte halt so ein bisschen der deutsche Anthony Jeselnik sagen.
Und ich will jetzt keinen Namen nennen, aber der hat dann, ist auf die Bühne gegangen, hat halt immer so Gags gemacht, die Anthony Jeselnik auch machen würde als Feedline. Er hat dann so etwas gesagt wie, ja, ich gucke Fussball ja nur wegen der Hooliganschlägereien. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, spannend, spannen Richtung und jetzt und dann war das der Joke. Und er hat die ganze Zeit immer solche Gags gemacht, die ganze Zeit, hat die ganze Zeit provoziert, aber da kam halt nichts dahinter. Und das Publikum war einfach wütend, es hat irgendwann gebugelt sogar, es war so hart und danach kam ich, dann hatte er einfach eine gute Show, weil es war halt einfach danach war das Publikum gesagt so, alles was jetzt kommt, ist besser, komm, gib mal einfach, behaupte einfach, dass ich dann... Du bist auch erst mal so auf die Bühne gegangen, der ist der Dead Guy, oder? Boah, das sind die schlimmsten Leute. Warst du ein Vollidiot, oder? Da können wir uns drauf einigen, oder? Ablauze. Aber das ist halt echt, ich weiss nicht, ich finde das immer sehr schwer, wenn man so Idole oder Ideale hat oder so, dass man, also ich persönlich, bei mir sorgt das dann auch, ich will mich gar nicht mit dem Messen. Ja, es ist immer die Gefahr. Ich hatte bei ihm auch so das Gefühl, dass es so einen Punkt gibt. Ich habe so das Gefühl, wenn dir plötzlich sehr viele Leute zuhören, hat das eine Wirkung auf dich. So, dass, glaube ich, Ricky Gervais, der hat ja wirklich ganz klein angefangen, als irgendwie Radiomoderator und irgendwie beschissen und ganz hoch gearbeitet. Und irgendwann fängt er dann an, nicht mehr über irgendwie, also ich finde gerade, The Office ist ja wirklich ein Lehrstück für Meta-Comedy und es geht ja um Comedy und es ist wirklich sehr intrinsisch und er arbeitet die Feinheiten raus, zwischen Menschlichkeit und Humor, zwischen Comedy-Persona und echten Menschen und Emotionalität und warum sind Menschen lustig, also wirklich ganz fein psychologisch und mittlerweile macht er Gags über Caitlyn Jenner, dass die eigentlich ja doch ein Mann ist. Und obwohl der sich halt umoperieren lassen eigentlich immer noch ein Mann ist. Wo ich mir denke, solche Art auch gar nicht, ob der Gag jetzt gut ist oder nicht, was er nicht war. Aber auch über diese Art von Dingen hat er früher nicht gesprochen. Aber er hat jetzt, weil er halt wahnsinnig viel auf Twitter und ständig die Likes und hier und da und wieder Skandal. weil, glaube ich, es gibt so einen Rausch von dir hören plötzlich viele Leute zu und du redest dann noch über Themen, die dir vielleicht gar nicht so liegen oder deinem eigenen Comedy-Stil gar nicht so liegen und alles, was er gesagt hat, das war so eine wahnsinnige Selbstinszenierung von, ja und dann hat irgendjemand geschrieben, man darf doch nicht über das und das lachen und dann sage ich, nein, man darf über alles lachen und der Tweet hat zu hundertusend Retwees bekommen. Und ich denke mir so, ja, wen interessiert das denn so? Erzähl mir das doch nicht so was von deinem Alltag und was du jetzt für tolle Sachen machst. Sondern er hat ja diese ganzen Botschaften und er hat ja auch viel verstanden, wie Menschen funktionieren und wie die Beziehungen zwischen Menschen funktionieren. Aber das fällt alles weg und wird Platz gemacht durch diesen Ich sag jetzt Dinge, die die Welt verändern könnten und sowas. Was mich aber da gar nicht interessiert. Das ist auch so ein bisschen so, glaube ich, dass der nicht geübt hat. Also der hat einfach nicht sein Programm sich erspielt, wie so ein Louis C.K., der dann wirklich immer in den Comedy-Seller geht und neues Material ausprobiert. Also dieses typisch amerikanische Ding. Und dann hat einer, mit dem wir da waren, bei Chris Rock gesagt, der hat einen Bekannten, der war mal im Comedy-Seller und plötzlich wurden alle Handys eingesammelt und dann kam Chris Rock auf die Bühne und hat einfach ein Set gespielt und dann war das nicht mehr kommen, das war ein kleiner Club, wo man einfach reingehen kann, wo man nicht mehr bezahlen muss, nicht mehr anstehen muss, wo man einfach reingehen kann. Und dann kamen halt nur so No-Names Leute, die Gags gemacht haben, die furchtbar waren, dann kam halt Chris Rock und dann wurden die Handys eingesammelt und so, das ist schon cool. Und dann merkt man halt auch, die testen neues Material und die bauen, die erspielen sich so eine Tour, also 90 Minuten lang und die gehen dann jahrlang einfach dann abends dahin und das macht Louis C.K. natürlich auch und den gibt es ja auch mega auf Comedy-Sellerns, wir haben ja auch Pete Holmes gesehen und so. War auch super gut und dann ist auch cool, man gönnt dir das auch so, dass man neues Material, das kann ja auch scheitern so, man freut sich ja auch darüber mal was zu sehen, was bombt von so jemandem, der so gut ist, das ist ja auch meistens dann auch irgendwie lustig. Aber ich glaube, gerade wenn du das so craftest wie ein Louis C. K. oder ein Chris Rock oder ein Chappelle oder so, die das alle machen, die irgendwie wirklich in diese dreckigen, versifften Comedy-Schuppen gehen und dort ihre Gags austesten und daran feilen. Und das ist auch in dieser Dokumentation von seinen Seiten von Comedien, wie die wirklich auch einfach nur einzelne Wörter austauschen und so Geschichten. Und ich glaube, bei Louis gibt es auch eine Folge, wo er das thematisiert.
Egal, auf jeden Fall dann die Chance, dass es dann, wenn du wirklich auf grosse Tour gehst oder ein Netflix-Special machst oder so,
dann die Chance, dass es dann nicht mehr klappt, ist sehr gering, weil du hast einfach so viele Probanden gehabt, an denen du es getestet hast,
wenn du halt, weiß ich nicht, deine 300 Shows pro Jahr machst und da sind jeweils so und so viele Leute und du weißt dann einfach, wo die lachen. Klar, es kann immer mal sein, dass ein Gag nicht funktioniert, weil sie die Referenz nicht checken oder so, aber generell checkst du es ja schon. Und keine Chance, dass Ricky Gervais das gemacht hat. Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht. Ja, da waren auch teilweise Gags dabei, die auf dem Papier nicht gut sind, die einfach nicht gut funktioniert haben. Das ist mir aber auch bei Chris Rock aufgefallen. Ich glaube, wenn er das Chris Rock Performance einfach aufgeschrieben hätte und durchgelesen hätte, es wäre nicht lustig gewesen. Der arbeitet ja generell viel durch seine Attitude und durch sein Delivery, aber trotzdem war ich da echt enttäuscht, dass teilweise wirklich, wenn man wirklich davon ausgeht, dass er jedes Wort feilt und jede Sache macht, da waren da teilweise Sachen drin, die einfach unsauber waren und so nicht funktioniert haben. Der hat einmal so einen Vergleich gebracht, irgendwie so It's like the atomic bomb of weapons. Wo ich mir dachte so, das ist doch kein Gag drin. Aber er sagt halt irgendwas anderes. It's like the atomic bomb of weapons! Ja, wo ich mir denke, das funktioniert auf dem Papier nicht. Das war unvieserabel. Chris Rock war okay, war okay. Sorry. Aber Chris Rock hat mich auch echt ein bisschen enttäuscht, es war auch nicht, hat auch nicht genau gehält. Ich glaube, dass das auch wieder was so ein bisschen mit dem Hunger und so zu tun hat. Die sind einfach so reich und die leben einfach mittlerweile in so anderen Sphären... Vor allem wie sammeln die noch Material. Ja. Die sitzen ja in ihrem riesen Villa und dann, ich stelle mir vor, dann reden die ganze Zeit und es heilt die ganze Zeit, weil da so ein großes Haus ist. Ja gut, ich meine, Chris Rock hat viel von seiner Scheidung erzählt, von seiner Ehe und so. Na gut, dann hast du immerhin was. Da hast du schon auf jeden Fall was. Ja, aber du verlierst schon den Boden auch so ein bisschen. Aber es ist natürlich schon was anderes, als wenn du irgendwie 20 bist und am Strugglen bist und irgendwie so auch noch so ein anderes Feuer. Ich merke das ja an mir selber, so dass ich einfach schon... Ausgebrannt. Naja, eine gewisse Müdigkeit nach 17 Jahren vor der Kamera ist dann schon irgendwie so, dass ich, also klar, ich habe vor zehn Jahren oder so habe ich immer noch Kolumben geschrieben und irgendwie gedacht, ich muss alles festhalten und jetzt denke ich mir so, lass mir alle die Ruhe, ich will einfach meine Ruhe. Das klingt bescheuert, aber das ist einfach nochmal, und ich glaube, wenn ich so reich wäre wie Chris Rock, würde man nichts mehr von mir sehen. Also wirklich, da bin ich auch, dann weiß ich nicht, vielleicht würde ich dann auch wirklich Stand-Up-Comedy machen, weil es mir dann scheißegal wäre, weil ich einfach mit so einem lachenden, mit so goldenen Grills, die ich mir kaufen würde, einfach auf die Bühne gehen würde. Und wenn die Leute nicht lachen, würde ich sie einfach mit Geld bewerben. Ach so eine Wasserpistole einfach, die da immer... Ja, aber es muss schon, ich will einfach dann, ich wäre so fucking arrogant, wenn ich reich wäre. Ihr merkt irgendwann, wenn ich irgendwann mal reich bin, merkt ihr mir das auf jeden Fall an. Ich würde es so krass raushängen lassen. Wie so Rapper, die aus der Hood kommen und dann irgendwie als erstes, wenn sie den ersten Scheck kriegen für ihr Album, als erstes erstmal 20 Goldketten kaufen und so und immer noch in einer Einzimmerwohnung wohnen. Einfach, das würde ich genau, ich würde es exakt genauso machen machen, richtig verbrassen, eine gute Woche haben.
Mich würde mal interessieren, ob die Leute
draußen erahnen können,
schätzen können, wie wir sitzen.
Das würde mich mal gerade interessieren, ob Leute
gerade schätzen können, wie wir sitzen,
ob die das hören, weil wir gucken
nämlich, schreibt es jetzt in die Kommentare,
wir gucken in eine Richtung, eigentlich wir sitzen vorne auf der Couch,
wir sitzen im Keller von Rocket Beans.
Das ist wie eine Panelshow.
Für mich ist vor allem unangegeben, weil ich sitze in der Mitte und immer wenn Stefan was sagt, muss ich nach links gucken. Ja, mega unangehen. Und dann höre ich dir zu und dann denke ich mir so, jetzt hat aber Florentin schon länger nichts mehr gesagt. Florentin braucht Aufmerksamkeit. Ja, genau. Und dann gucke ich rüber. Ja, ich will auch was sagen. Ist aber tatsächlich... Und bei Louis C.K. war es auch so. Da sassen wir nämlich, wir sassen nämlich auf einer Tribüne und links war die Bühne. Heißt, man hat die ganze Zeit nach links geguckt,
weil da Louis C.K. war, weil irgendwann dachte ich mir,
Florentin hat auch gleich keine Aufmerksamkeit bekommen.
Und dann habe ich mich einfach so zu ihm, da dachte ich mir,
wenn dem Ding ein Fremder sitzt,
dann muss ich einfach mal so umdrehen, einfach mal
ihn angucken, guck mal, wie er reagiert.
Irgendwann hat er wehgetan, ich dachte mir, ich muss zum Ausgleich mal nach rechts gucken
und dann guckst du halt einfach
die Kardjana an, einfach ein paar Minuten lang.
Und das finde ich ja sympathisch, dass du bei Louis C.K. live warst und dir Gedanken gemacht hast, ob Florentin genug Aufmerksamkeit bekommt. Er kriegt da nichts mehr Aufmerksamkeit. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich habe tatsächlich ein bisschen zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit. Aber du bist mehr böse. Jetzt ist mal Louis C.K. zwei Stunden der Star. Na gut. Geht mal einfach nicht um dich, okay? Ich möchte übrigens an der Stelle ganz kurz sagen, dass ich ihr wisst es vielleicht nicht, aber als Pop-Schutz haben wir originale schwarze Socken. Wir haben die Socken wieder mitgenommen. Socken über dem Mikrofon und ich habe, glaube ich, während ich geredet habe, das Mikrofon ab und zu mal gedreht und nicht immer in die richtige Richtung reingesprochen. Das ist kein Problem. Das ist soundtechnisch. Wir legen bei dir ohnehin noch so ein paar Roboter-Effekte drauf und so, dann macht das keine Hallen. So ein Kirchenhall. Ich merke schon, es entsteht schon so ein leichter Abmoderations-Vive. Ehrlich jetzt? Du musst doch weg. Ja, geht so. Ja, ist gleich. Noch mal entspannter. Ich muss ja auch ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe so lange drauf gewartet, dass ihr endlich mal anfragt. Man kann sich ja nicht schlecht selber ins Gespräch bringen. Könnt ihr immer gerne unter zentrale-podcast-ufo.fail, wenn ihr Bock habt, Gaste sein, schreibt uns. Gibt es so ein paar Gäste, wo ihr sagt, den hättet ihr gerne? Also den habt ihr euch noch nicht getraut? Ja doch, klar. Also ganz realistisch, ich sage nicht, was der passt, Hefgar sowas mag. Wir haben uns lange bei Jan nicht getraut, Bimmelmann haben wir dann irgendwann mal getraut. Aber wieso, den habt ihr doch täglich gesehen. Wir sind ja große Fans auch selber und man ist auch sehr verschüchtert. Wir waren auch sehr verschüchtert. Wir waren auch nicht so gut in der Folge. Aber das ist generell, das habe ich auch bei der Folge mit Maxi gemerkt, ihr seid ja sehr unterwürfig gewesen. Das war natürlich auch noch vor zwei Jahren und so, aber ihr seid gar nicht so selbstbewusst. Überhaupt nicht. Überhaupt nicht richtig.
Aber wo kommt das denn her?
Natürlich sind wir nicht selbstbewusst.
Wir sind die neurotischsten Vollidioten,
die die ganze Zeit selber in Frage stellen, was die ganze Zeit machen.
Das ist alles nur
Überkompensation, wenn wir nach außen gehen.
Ja, aber ist es wirklich so oder ist es auch so ein bisschen
eine Rolle, dass ihr denkt,
so ein bisschen Neurosen
gehört zu guten Comedien auch dazu. Ja, ich denke mir manchmal, stehe ich vor dem Spiegel und denke mir so, du bist schon ganz geil, was du so erreicht hast, und dann denke ich mir manchmal aber auch, du bist einfach das Letzte, wie kannst du überhaupt erwarten, dass Leute dir zuhören? Es ist wirklich ausgeliefert. Es gibt so viel schlechtere Sachen da draußen, wie sollen die Leute sich denn dann fühlen? Das ist ja fast schon ein Understatement, das ist ja fast schon eine Form von Arroganz, wenn ihr dauernd euch so unterwerft den Leuten und so, weil dafür seid ihr halt objektiv, ihr seid auch zu schlau, ihr müsst ja wissen, dass ihr objektiv auch ein bisschen was könnt, sonst wärt ihr ja nicht an den Stellen, wo ihr seid, weil es kann ja nicht sein, dass ihr einerseits Böhmermann vergöttert und andererseits sagt, ihr seid voll Idioten, aber ihr seid in seiner Firma und arbeitet für ihn. Es passt irgendwie nicht zusammen. Man hat bis zum Ende das Gefühl, dass man da nicht sein darf, dass man da nicht hingehört. Bei mir war es wirklich, also irgendwann dann nicht mehr so stark, aber ich dachte mir immer so, eigentlich ich bin hier nur durch Glück und durch Zufall und ich darf eigentlich hier gar nicht sein, ich hab's mir gar nicht verdient und gleich fliege ich auf. Gleich fliegt auf, dass ich gar nichts kann und dann bin ich sofort wieder raus. Das dachte ich bei Star Wars Chat heute. Gleich fliegt auf, dass ich eigentlich keine Ahnung von Star Wars. Und man denkt so, okay, ich hab vielleicht noch eine Woche bevor es auffliegt, ich hab vielleicht noch zwei Wochen bevor es auffliegt und dann irgendwann sagt man, vielleicht hab ich noch ein Jahr bevor es auffliegt und irgendwann denkt man sich wahrscheinlich so, ich hab jetzt noch drei Staffeln bevor es auffliegt und so arbeitet man sich dann da durch. Das hab ich aber auch immer noch. Bei mir ist es nur, bei dir ist es halt wirklich ja auch Glück gewesen, dass du reingekommen bist, muss man einfach so sagen. Es war einfach wirklich Glück. Es ist doch immer irgendwie Glück, dass es irgendwie klappt. Natürlich, aber bei mir war es halt noch eine Bewerbung, eine klassische, was jetzt nicht heißt, dass ich jetzt irgendwie das mehr verdient habe, da zu sein in der Firma, aber im Grunde ist es so. Aber trotzdem findet genau diese gleiche Rationalisierung statt, dass ich mir die ganze Zeit denke, du hast es nicht verdient, hier zu sein. Obwohl es halt dabei noch schwieriger ist als jetzt bei dir, wo Frank Elzer dich mitgenommen hat. Das ist natürlich einfach eine andere Aneinanderkettung von Ereignissen. Aber es ist manchmal total absurd, gerade bei so einem Dreh denke ich mir oft so, und wir bei guter Arbeit haben ja das Glück, relativ gross zu drehen, mit einer grossen Crew und so, mit Catering und Leuten und dann Praktikanten und so, dann ist so ein Set relativ gross, 20 Leute, manchmal denke ich mir schon so, die sind jetzt alle da, die sind alle heute Morgen aufgestanden, die sind alle zur Uni gegangen, haben das gelernt mit den Kameras und so, und die sind alle aufgestanden heute Morgen und haben sich aus dem Bett gequält, um heute mich hier zu filmen, mich, Alle zwanzig sind da, um mich zu filmen. Oder denkt man sich schon,
um Katja und mich zu filmen. Das ist schon krass,
aber auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir oft so,
all die brauchen ja jemanden,
der vor der Kamera steht. So dieses ganze
Entertainment-System braucht Leute,
die vor der Kamera stehen.
Es braucht genauso wie jemand einen Kameramann
braucht, braucht es auch dich. Und deswegen denke ich mir auch immer so,
und da versuche ich immer daran zu denken,
was Will Ferrell mal gesagt hat im Interview, so dieses Don't believe the hype, so es braucht das System, das System braucht Leute wie dich. Don't believe the hype kommt von Will Ferrell? Absolut, habe ich zumindest von Will Ferrell gehört. Aber es ist so, dass es dieses System einfach braucht Leute, die vor der Kamera stehen, einfach weil es das System ist und nicht weil du jetzt vielleicht wahnsinnig krass bist. Aber irgendjemand muss halt vor der Kamera stehen. Das ist genauso wie irgendjemand muss im Lotto gewinnen. Aber so bescheiden würde ich es gar nicht sehen. Das klingt ja jetzt fast so, ja ja, die akzeptieren mich, weil sie halt jemanden brauchen, den sie abfilmen müssen. Ich bin immer noch besser als ein Stück Tapete. Aber ich meine zum Beispiel, wo das mit dem Hype vielleicht besser passt, ist, wenn jemand zum Beispiel jetzt von der Klatschpresse wahnsinnig hochgeschrieben wird. Und plötzlich der neue Schlagerstar ist in jeder Zeitung und so und der Schlagerstar denkt sich, oh, ich bin der krasseste Mensch der Welt. Aber der weiss ja auch, diese Schlagerzeit, diese Schmierblätter brauchen Leute, über die sie schreiben, die suchen aktiv, wen können wir jetzt berühmt machen. Wir brauchen schnell irgendjemanden, damit wir mit dem Auflage machen. und die sind heilfroh, dass sie irgendjemanden hochpushen können. Egal, ob der das gewährt ist oder ob der das verdient, weil das System basiert darauf, Leute groß, Leute wieder runter. Ich hatte irgendwann mal so einen Moment, wo ich dachte, jetzt habe ich gerade irgendwie so die Matrix durchschaut oder sowas. Es ist nicht so der Mega-Moment, aber bei mir ist er bis heute in Erinnerung geblieben, war bei der ganzen Edward Snowden-Berichterstattungung, habe ich mir immer gedacht, wenn der die Entscheidung nicht getroffen hätte, wären die ganzen Zeitungen von dem Moment bis jetzt leer. Und dann ist mir ein, nee, werden sie nicht. Die hätten schon irgendwas anderes gefunden. Aber dieses Gedankenexperiment, dass immer was passieren muss, weil Leute immer aktiv nach etwas suchen, was passiert, ist halt schon interessant. Genau das meine ich, die Kamera läuft den ganzen Tag und egal wer davor steht, der ist halt dann jetzt auf der Schlagzeile, aber die Kamera hört nicht auf. Aber mir geht es eigentlich eher darum, wir waren ja beim Selbstverständnis oder Selbstvertrauen oder nennen wir es mal Selbstbewusstsein, also damit meine ich nicht, dass man denkt, man ist der Allergeilste, aber dass man sich halt seiner selbstbewusst ist, also auch seiner Stärken und seiner Schwächen. Und kein Mensch hat ja nur Schwächen. Mancher mehr. Dankeschön. Nein, aber weißt du, also zum Beispiel bei mir ist, ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass ich der selbstbewussteste Mensch bin. In manchen Dingen bin ich selbstbewusst, in manchen bin ich es überhaupt nicht so. Wo bist du gar nicht selbstbewusst? Zum Beispiel Frauen anquatschen, da war ich immer schlecht. Ultraschlecht. Und ich rede wirklich vom Inszenierungsprozess. Wenn es irgendwie die Situation erfordert, dass man auf eine natürliche Art und Weise, was ja nie passiert. Natürlich sein. Natürlich sein ist schon schwierig. Ja, einfach irgendwie, ich habe immer versagt, wenn es darum ging, Frauen irgendwie diesen ersten Kontakt herzustellen. Teilweise habe ich einfach kein Wort rausgekriegt oder einfach saudumm geantwortet. Ich war nicht mehr ich selbst. Es war einfach irgendeine Version. Und jedes Mal habe ich mir gedacht, die müssen denken, du bist der grösste Vollidiot. Rund in 80 Prozent der Fall haben die sich auch gedacht. Aber das meine ich halt, es gibt Momente, da bin ich eben nicht selbstbewusst. Aber es gibt Dinge, da weiß ich ich, das kann ich oder da fühle ich mich wohl, sagen wir es mal so. Ich sage nicht, da bin ich gut drin, aber da fühle ich mich wohl, da fühle ich mich in meinem Element. Und ich glaube, das ist schon mal der erste Schritt für so ein Selbstbewusstsein, was du brauchst, wenn du auf die Bühne gehst. Mit Bühne meine ich scheissegal, ob ob das jetzt ein Sketchshow ist oder sobald du nach draußen ins Showbiz im weitesten Sinne gehst, wo Leute bewerten, was du ablieferst. Da brauchst du ein gewisses Selbstbewusstsein. Wenn du dauernd Angst hast davor, dass die Leute dich scheiße finden oder so, dann funktioniert es nicht. Dann glaube ich nicht, dass du die Strahlkraft hast, das zu machen. Das siehst man zum Beispiel auch sehr an Jan Böhmermann. Ich kenne ihn ja jetzt überhaupt nicht privat oder so. Aber der strahlt in den Podcasts und in der Sendung ein unglaubliches Selbstbewusstsein aus. Er hat zu jedem Thema eine Meinung, er hat zu jedem Thema die richtige offensichtlich, er weiss viel und so. Und selbst wenn er über irgendwas sagt, dass er es nicht weiss, klingt es trotzdem souverän, wisst ihr, wie ich meine? Und das ist eine Form, die alle Late-Night-Shows Hosts haben, weshalb ich auch der Meinung bin, dass Jan Mimmern prädestiniert ist für diesen Job, den er da macht, weil er diese Charakteristik hat, anders zum Beispiel als eine Anke Engelke, die das versucht hat, irgendwie über, ha, ich bin gar nicht so gut, das funktioniert nicht, du musst rausgehen und sagen, gib mir das Mike, mach den fucking Vorhang auf.
One, two, three, funny.
Und jetzt, ja genau, gib mir das Mike, ich zeige euch, ich mache euch jetzt anderthalb Stunden und wenn du danach depressiv zusammenbrichst und dann in der Dusche duschst und der traurigste Mensch der Welt bist, fucking who cares.
Aber in dem Moment, wo das Rotlicht angeht, gehst du raus und du weisst einfach, die Leute hängen dir an den Lippen und ich hab da Bock, ich hab Bock drauf, das zu machen, ich bin ein extrovertiertes Arschloch, ihr wollt eine gute Laune sehen und die kriegt die jetzt und das ist so ein Vertrag, den man schliesst und ich glaube, das ist dieses Selbstverständnis, nicht vielleicht jetzt in allen Extrem, die ich jetzt genannt habe, aber als Comedy-Autor genauso wie als was auch immer du halt machst, diese Selbstüberzeugung, dass du gerade das Richtige machst, dass du gerade das machst, was du gerne machst und wo du dich wohlfühlst. Das ist, glaube ich, eine ganz wichtige Voraussetzung, um Erfolg zu haben. Und das heißt nicht, dass man nicht bescheiden sein darf. Jan Böhmermann geht ja jetzt auch nicht hin und sagt, ich bin der allergeilste Typ der Welt oder so. Man kann ja trotzdem bescheiden und bodenständig sein, aber man muss das Gefühl haben, ich kann das, was ich gerade mache. Ich fühle mich da wohl. Das hatte ich zum Beispiel bei Stand-up nicht. Da hatte ich nicht diese, klar, ich habe es auch nur einmal in meinem Leben gemacht und ich glaube, bei meinem ersten Auftritt bei Giga bin ich auch nicht rausgegangen und gesagt, geh mal zur Seite oder gib mir mal das Mikrofon oder so. Das hat natürlich auch was mit Routine und so weiter zu, man hat das nicht von Anfang an, aber generell habe ich schon relativ, das fängt bei mir ja an in der Schule schon, dass ich die Aufmerksamkeit wollte, ja, also ich war halt der. Bei mir im Zeugnis, von der ersten Klasse steht, von der zweiten Klasse steht, Stefan gelingt es jetzt besser, seinen Äusserungsdrang unter Kontrolle zu halten. Und es ist, glaube ich, bei jedem von jemandem, der dann so einen Podcast macht oder so, stand so einen Satz mal im Zeugnis. Ich glaube, das ist halt einfach dann drin in uns. Ganz kurz, Eddie, du bist ja recht beliebt. Da will ich ganz kurz. Also bei den Rocket Beans an sich, auch von den Moderatoren bist du einer der beliebtesten. Wie kommst du da drauf? Das ist so, wie ich war. Dieseimmst. Oder auch von den Klickzahlen oder so. Hast du denn manchmal das Gefühl, du würdest das irgendwann verlieren, dass du irgendwas falsch machst und du bist nicht mehr beliebt oder dass du irgendwie, dass die Leute dich nicht mehr unterstützen und irgendwann weg sind? Ob ich die Angst davor habe oder was? Also das würde ja erstmal voraussetzen, dass ich das auch so wahrnehme. Und das tue ich nicht. Also ich sehe natürlich auch, dass mein Moin Moin viele Klicks hat. Ich sehe aber natürlich auch immer die roten Ampeln. Also ich sehe auch, wie oft ich beleidigt werde oder angemotzt werde oder wie oft mir jemand unterstellt, wie unfassbar dumm ich bin und wie unfassbar schlau Nils ist. Er ist schon schlau. Ja, ist er ja auch. Defensiv. Ja, ist er. Ist er ja auch. Habe ich euch nichts gesagt? Und? So, komm. Aber also, mir ist halt schon klar, dass ich auch polarisiere und dass es halt auch viele Leute gibt, die das auch... Ich lehne mich natürlich auch weit aus dem Fenster in vielen Dingen. Und ich denke mir aber halt, also ich kriege auch viel Fett ab, das will ich damit sagen. Und ich habe einfach irgendwie für mich festgestellt, da bin ich tatsächlich so ein bisschen arrogant, dass ich einfach, ich glaube schon, dass ich, ich will jetzt diesen Podcast nicht auf so einer unsympathischen Note enden lassen. Wir schneiden den dann noch und es wird so hart. Egal was du jetzt sagst, ich schneide das mega arrogant. Okay, also ich sag mal so, ich bin der Überzeugung, wenn die Leute mich scheiße finden, dann sind sie selber scheiße, weil sie es dann einfach nicht raffnet. Da musste ich gar nichts mehr schneiden, das war schon per se sehr. Also das ist wirklich so, das ist auch schon in der Schule so bei mir gewesen, dass die, die mich nicht leiden konnten, waren halt die Vollidioten. Aus meiner Sicht. Bei mir waren es alle Schüler und die Lehrer am Morgen. Ja. Und ich habe mich halt einfach damit abgefunden, dass ich dann halt nur drei Kumpels hatte, aber das waren für mich auch die drei Richtigen. Und das ist genau wie diese Star Wars Frage bei Chatuelluell, wir können ja jetzt drüber reden, das ist ja die Ausstellung von hier, wo die Frage war, in welcher Reihenfolge guckst du es? Und du hast genau richtig gesagt, 90% gucken, die ist in der Reihenfolge 46. Wir haben es richtig beantwortet, hast du gesagt. Und der Chat hat es falsch beantwortet. Ich habe gesagt, wir haben es richtig beantwortet. Und das ist meiner Meinung nach, genau so sehe ich es dann in dem Moment eigentlich auch, wenn ich sage, okay, du hast nicht gerafft, wie ich es meine, oder du hast den Gag nicht gerafft, oder du glaubst, weil ich jetzt sage, irgendwie, wenn du Veganer bist, verpiss dich vom Grill, dass wirklich meine Meinung ist, dass alle Veganer asoziale Spasten sind, und ich würde mich privat nicht mitreden. Wenn du jemand bist, der dann in die Comments geht und das schreibt, hast du dich in meiner Welt disqualifiziert und ich habe gar kein Interesse mehr an deiner Meinung. Wenn jetzt einer von euch sagen würde, boah ja, Alter, was für ein Idiot, ja, dann das wäre schon, das würde wehtun. Oder irgendjemand, den man selber halt gut findet oder mit dem man sich auf einer Wellenlänge sieht oder so. Das sind dann die Sachen, die wehtun. Aber wenn es irgendein anonymer Typ auf YouTube irgendwie sagt, finde ich scheiße, ja gut. Wenn es halt wirklich keiner mehr guckt, dann ist es so, dann müsste ich halt was anderes machen. Aber habe ich die Frage überhaupt irgendwie beantwortet? Das war, liebe Leute, in Chenga-Ding. Ja, ich bin auch schon. Aber freut mich, dass du zuversichtlich bist. Wir müssen das leider abmoderieren, weil ich echt dringend nach Hause muss. Das war bei mir jetzt so nach Hamburg, nach Köln. Aber man kann mit dir ja eh, also wenn man bei dir ein Thema anfängt, dann kann man ja eh da ... Ja, sorry. Ich glaube auch wieder super viel Lager. Ich denke mir auch mal bei Almost Daily, es gibt so viele Almost Daily, dann ballert er draußen, ballert er draußen, in jedem zweiten dein Gesicht zu sehen. Dann denke ich mir auch so, wie geht das, aber mit dir kann man wirklich überein, das ist wirklich ein großes Kompliment. Man kann mit dir, wenn man ein Thema anfängt, kann man damit tagelang füllen. Ich finde das aber auch unterhaltsam und das macht Spaß und deswegen vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Und das würde ich damit sagen, wir werden dich auch bestimmt noch häufiger zu Gast haben. Also ich komme gerne wieder. Also ich habe nicht über alle Themen gesprochen. Ich auch nicht. Ich habe noch so viele Fragen und das Lustige ist, ich habe den Podcast mit Donny O'Sullivan neulich gehört und ich habe den gehört und ich fand ihn sehr gut. Donny ist ja auch so ein Entertainment-Typ, der ja auch dann das finde ich auch vollkommen in Ordnung. Aber dann habe ich auch da gesessen und gesagt, Mann Donny, jetzt halt doch mal die Luft, dann lass dir die anderen beiden auch mal was sagen. So habe ich gedacht. Und jetzt sitze ich hier und habe Original Florentina drei Sätze gesagt, du hast sechs Sätze gesagt. Ich habe das Ding komplett einfach hier nur gelabert und es tut mir schon wieder leid.
Jetzt kein Problem, dafür bist du da.
Nein, aber wir haben uns eingeladen, wir sind auch noch häufiger bezieht. Ich könnte halt auch vier Stunden noch mit uns sagen.
Deswegen heisst die Folge Etienga D1.
Ja, das ist gut, das finde ich schön, das finde ich gut.
Ja, vielen Dank an Etienga D, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast.
Vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal und wir heben ab.